foreign
[Music]
it's a farmer directed Grant arm from
the USDA that started in 1988 with the
farm bill because the USDA knew that
farmers are always on The Cutting Edge
to find applied solutions to their
problems that they have Liz Brownlee Liz
and her husband Nate raise livestock on
pasture at nightfall Farm in southeast
Indiana they sell via farmers markets
restaurants and independent groceries
but their meat and egg CSA is the
Cornerstone of their Farm they typically
have 50 families in their CSA and over
90 percent retention
they raise meat chickens laying hens
sheep pigs and turkeys on 50 acres Liz
works as director of farm farmer
programs for partners in food and
farming pif which I would love to hear
more about that too Liz
um so my husband and I farm in southeast
Indiana We're practically in Kentucky
and so we are in a very rural space
we're right where the glaciers stopped
if you can picture it so it goes from
flat flat flat flat flat to hilly
um and we're on my family's farm so we
worked on farms up in New England for
about five years learning worked on
organic farms and most of them had csas
and we learned a ton from seeing that
behind the scenes reality so if you're
still in that aspiring phase I highly
encourage you to or even if you're
already Farm but you're thinking of
adding a CSA find somebody who has a CSA
near you and work on their Farm to help
with distro I would love for somebody to
offer that to me if you're near me come
help me with pickup days and see what
it's like what the decisions are behind
the scenes what the stress points are in
organizing pickup days things like that
um we saw it work really well both as
collaborative csas where 14 farmers were
working together in Pennsylvania and
doing a unified share we saw individual
Farms doing meat csas that really worked
and that's what got us excited so we
actually run a meat and egg CSA only no
vegetables
um and we've mostly talked about veggies
and meat so far but I'll add you
mentioned soup right we've seen soup
csas and cheese csas and bread csas and
all sorts of cool stuff we stick to the
non-perishables and I would say that's
one of the keys to our CSA is that um
there is no getting overwhelmed because
if you don't have time to cook that week
you throw it in the freezer and as long
as you don't do that with six
consecutive months of chicken you're
gonna be fine
um Okay so let me zoom out a little bit
now that you know roughly who I am and
where I'm from
um I wanted to say on the the Sarah
grants
raise your hand
if you love Sarah farmer Rancher grants
who's already in love oh I can convince
a bunch of you then okay great so if you
don't already know Sarah has a bunch of
different sorts of Grants and their
farmer Rancher grants are specifically
for farmers who are doing something
Innovative trying something out that's
either new to their state let's say
maybe in Michigan they're killing it
with X practice they know how to grow
you know I don't know something really
neat like they can grow mushrooms on an
urban farm and I'm an urban farm in
Indiana and nobody's doing that I could
apply for a Sarah Grant to take a known
idea that's Innovative and sustainable
and try it in my place
or if there's just an idea that I
haven't heard of anybody else trying I
could apply for funds to do that thing
so the surrogant that my farm that we
applied for we went into Cahoots with
another Farm because here's another cool
thing about Sarah grants you can ask for
money
I think it's up to nine thousand dollars
per for one Farm but if you go in with
others you can ask for more money which
is even better so we had two Farms so we
asked for like 18 Grand and if you go up
to three Farms you can ask for twenty
seven thousand dollars
a lot of money
um it's not going to change the world
but it might change your farm so that's
the other key thing is that you can
really think strategically about how a
Sarah Grant can not only research and
trial something Innovative and help
other Farmers because a key piece of it
is that you're sharing out whatever you
learn you share through talks or videos
or some way to get the word out because
the whole idea is this is government
money right they don't want it just to
help one individual business they want
it to help lots of farmers
but also can you use that Sarah Grant as
a way to take some big step forward
so for our CSA with meat a big
bottleneck was processing that's a
problem for Farmers all across the
Midwest all across the nation in fact
and so we wanted to find out what is the
very smallest processing facility that
you could open
and make money
how small could it get
because our our farm and our friend's
Farm Palmer Bowers Farmstead they raise
cattle we do sheep and turkeys and
chickens and and pigs and for all of
those animals it's really hard to get a
butcher date and maybe you know this
well
um you know in in March I called on the
first day the butcher was taken butcher
dates for sheep and they said How's
December 27th and I said sold I'll take
it because that was the only date I
could get you're scheduling months if
not years out at this point so we wanted
to know could we open our own on-farm
processing facility that would be State
inspected and would it ever pencil out
would we make any money so our project
was actually a feasibility study
um because
we felt like we've kind of got the CSA
thing working and their Farm felt like
they had the freezer beef thing working
it wasn't selling our product that was
the problem it was getting from animal
to product
um and so we hired some fancy people who
knew how to do the math and we paid
ourselves to meet every month for two
years to work through these questions
and we worked with a chef and and
basically we put together a really cool
set of resources that we have not
utilized so we've actually decided not
to open a processing facility
at this point they might they're like
thinking about it and working on the the
local zoning things needed to open the
facility
um but in some ways that's what a
feasibility is supposed a feasibility
study is supposed to do help you decide
do I want this or not and I would say
once a month at least somebody emails us
out of the blue and said hey I found
your thing online about your Sarah
project and we're thinking about opening
a facility in fill in the blank state
and it was really helpful because we
hadn't yet seen a free floor plan and
layout for a really small facility we
hadn't yet seen an equipment list of
what you'd need
um so we developed all those tools and
now they live on our website
um and if that's useful to you I'm not
trying to get clicks because these don't
do me any good but nightfallfarm.com
and there's like an about us and you
click processing
um and Sarah paid for all of that
and so we really wanted to get out to
other farmers and be useful to other
Farmers it's not directly helping our
CSA
which is kind of a bummer it's not
directly helping our farm although it
did probably save us a lot of money I
think it helped us realize like wow that
could that could pencil out we came up
with a budget for a three species so all
red meat right lamb pork beef uh
facility that'd be open with one and a
half employees and it can pencil out in
10 years it'll pay for itself and it'll
be viable but we realized like wow we
don't want to do that
sounds miserable
we just we decided that that wasn't for
us
um because you would that would be
all the work every single week
um whereas right now my husband and I
are one and a half people farming and
we've that helped us realize we want to
be outside farming
so that was our stair project what do we
do on our farm
um I wanted to tell you
let's see so when we moved home to
Indiana
um we wanted our farm to be a piece of
the solution on climate change and on
rebuilding our rural communities so
that's really been the focus
and you were spot on that the first yeah
your first chunk of CSA members are
people you know so our first year we
started with 12 CSA members and we knew
every one of them and um and now we're
at 50 really consistently and we really
like that number that's what our firm
can sustain
um
our our rural Place could not have a 400
member CSA I don't know 400 people who
would buy a CSA and um and that's okay
that's where we're at it's a pretty poor
Community
um and and
for a lot of people value means cheap so
finding our members has been a really
interesting process you would think that
our members are all uh well to do and
they are not we have a lot of school
secretaries and non-profit workers and
military families and Factory workers we
also have doctors and professors but
it's a real cross-section and I think
the unifying thing is that people
prioritize good food
so they they might come to us for a
really wide breadth of reasons so some
people when we ask why are you joining
they say oh I care about the environment
and other people say oh it's for Humane
Animal practices and other people say I
want to support small businesses in my
local community but when we ask why they
stay they say it's because it tastes
good
and that makes me really happy
and so we get these people who wouldn't
normally interact standing in line to
pick up their CSA share interacting and
that feels like a real win
um
let's see what else about the CSA in
terms of connection I want to add to
your connection list so
um we do things like tree plantings and
potlucks recipe books things like that
for our CSA members we're going to make
t-shirts this winter we're gonna have
like a t-shirt making party that should
be fun
um and then just to bring it back to the
CSA or to the sale project I do still
hope to make jerky
if anybody out there has figured out how
to do jerky in a commercial kitchen well
following all the rules let me know I
haven't figured it out yet but that the
Sarah project did really help us realize
like oh
even though we're gonna have to deal
with those longer wait times at The
Butcher and schedule way ahead there are
still some other pieces of that
processing and value-added puzzle that
we think we could solve and maybe that's
another share Grant I don't know
um because people don't all love lamb
but almost everyone loves jerky and if
that jerky happened to be made of lamb I
think they'd be okay with it so we're
trying to figure these things out you
know how do we offer things that make
our CSA members lives easier and sell
the products that that we want to raise
[Music]